[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de si on parler sport sur tv78
l'émission à ne surtout pas manquer si
vous êtes un passionné de sport local
aujourd'hui il y aura comme toujours des
des analyses techniques des décryptages
et surtout une dose de bonne humeur pour
m'accompagner nos chroniqueurs sont avec
nous sur ce plateau et ils sont en très
grande forme présentation on commence à
ma droite musique c'est l'un des PER
fondateurs de cette émission il adore le
sport et plus particulièrement le
pyclisme il n'hésite jamais à aller au
combat pour défendre ses idées notre
capitaine y du jarier est avec nous
pendant une heure comment ça va très
très bien toujours toujours quand on est
sur le plateau on approche de Noël aussi
on approche de Noël oui oui vivement
Friday pour finaliser les cadeaux plein
de cadeaux pour pour vous ce vendredi du
coup voilà on continue à gauche musique
vous reconnaissez sa musique c'est un
véritable italien il adore la cuisine
italienne il adore passer ses vacances
en Italie dans son village de Diamante
comme tous les italien il aime le sport
et surtout le football en F1 il supporte
à Scuderia Ferrari notre italien lover
Gregory canal est avec nous bonsoir
Michel bonsoir bonsoir à tous que de
stéréotype l'Italie la Ferrari en
Formule 1 la Juventus dans le football
voilà plein de plein d'équipes à
supporter vous confirmez en tout cas je
confirme oui tout à fait que je suis
derrière la la Scuderia Ferrari bien sûr
vous vivez Italie je vis Italie à 100 %.
on passe de l'autre côté à musique il
n'était pas présent sur la dernière
émission mais il est bien là avec nous
aujourd'hui c'est un véritable
combattant lui aussi aime aller au
combat et donner quelques coups de
points dans la mêlée mais rassurez-vous
il n'est pas méchant lors des 3è
mi-temps notre gladiateur per chevalier
du Rugby Club de Versailles est avec
nous pendant une heure for bonheur à
tous salut les copains glad to be back
et oui effectivement les trisè mi-temps
ça se fait de manière beaucoup plus
glissé beaucoup plus pas de coup de PO
pendant les TR non pas besoin non non
pas besoin avection surtout pas besoin
avec avec avec modération alors nous
aurons seulement trois chroniqueurs avec
nous aujourd'hui mais ils sont tellement
bons qu'ils feront le travail de quatre
chroniqueurs sur ce plateau mais nous
aurons avec nous un invité de prestige
en visio le skipper vers ça y est
musique on écoute le skipper versaillais
éc bon est avec nous il a terminé 9e du
vent des globes en 2017 il a fini 23e de
la route du Rome en 2022 et il a
malheureusement abandonné sur cette
Transat Jacques Vabre 2023 alors comment
allez-vous ériic comment allez-vous
ben comme un marin qui a pris le départ
d'une course qui est resta que 24 heur
en course et qui a R cé un OFNI et qui
est rentré à la maison un peu la queue
entre les jambes bon on en par on en
parlera un petit peu plus tard dans
l'émission vous gardez quand même le
moral j'ai des haut et des bas mais là
je vais récupérer mon bateau donc c'est
plutôt un haut mais non je j'aime pas
abandonner on verra ça un peu plus tard
dans cette émission alors avant de
passer au programme de l'émission et de
parler de la Transat Jacques Vabre 2023
on va parler football ou plutôt cuisine
le pariss-germain est devenu le premier
club de football français édité un livre
de cuisine assez à couleur cet ouvrage
intitulé à table avec le pariss
sa-germain met en avant 70 recettes de
cuisine des joueurs emblématiques du
club le livre est tout de même signé par
le chef doublement étoilé David touttin
chacun des joueurs il présente SEP de
leurs recettes favorites la ferroada à
la manière de marquinos je sais pas si
je le prononce bien que vous dire voilà
exactement exactement ça pour marquos le
couscous de légumes d'enfance d'Achraf
Hakimi la recette de crêpe de prnel Kem
B alors la question sur cette thématique
on valide ou pas oui ou non non vous ne
validez pas pierre non pour vous Yan et
oui pour vous Grégory alors pourquoi
grégoryi non Mo dis rigolant jamais les
premiers parce que c'est vrai que les
supporters parisiens disent souvent au
marseillais qui n'ont pas vraiment gagné
la Ligue des Champions les supporters
marseillais disent à jamais les problè
parce que c'est le seul club français
qui a gagné la Ligue des Champions et
bien le parissgermain restera dans
l'histoire comme le premier club à
sortir son livre de cuisine non mais moi
je valite quand même la démarche blague
à part même si dedans je sais pas s'ils
ont mis la recette pour gagner la la
Ligue des Champions mais je ne pense pas
que ce soit encore le cas moi je pense
que avant tout bon c'est une opération
marketing une opération de communication
c'est pour essayer de rapprocher le
public de ces joueurs même si ce sont
des joueurs qui gagnent ce sont des
joueurs qui gagnent des millions d'euros
bah ils ont peut-être les mêmes goûts
culinaires que nous moi je trouve que
c'est bien aussi d'apprendre à mieux les
connaître des souvenirs d'enfance comme
celui lu d'ashrafakimi et ce ce couscous
que lui préparait sa sa famille donc moi
je pense que c'est une bonne opération
de communication on arrive bientôt au
faites ça rapproche le public des
joueurs donc oui la démarche peut faire
sourire et on attend avant tout d'un
club de de sport de foot qu'il gagne
mais je pense que d'avoir des petites
opérations marketing comme ça ça ça fait
de mal à personne vous allez tenter le
couscous légumes d'fimi peut-être et la
recette de crêpe de pressnel surtout Yan
jarier qu'est-ce que vous en pensez euh
j'en
pense enfin je ouais pour moi c'est
ridicule j' aurais trouvé un intérêt en
allant sur un autre sur un angle
complètement différent
c'est-à-dire donner l'envie au aux gens
de manger équilibré de manger sainement
et bien justement et les recettes sont
été analysées par un nutritionniste du
club ou dans en se disant voilà ce sont
les repas que mange
tel pour pouvoir être performance sur
les compétitions pour voilà dans lesord
veut pas qu'il mange au quotidien et là
je pense que oui ça aurait pu il y
aurait eu un intérêt de se dire ben
voilà comment est-ce qu'il mange pour
pouvoir bah peut-être l'adapté aussi à
mon à mon alimentation et du coup bah
manger le le manger sain aujourd'hui on
est tous tout le monde B le recherche là
en effet se dire les grands champions
voilà les grands sportifs les sportifs
de haut niveau comment est-ce qu'ils
s'alimentent quels sont les ingrédients
les les les plats qui qu'ils aiment et
peut-être ben du coup avoir des recettes
pour pouvoir les prendre moi si ça avait
été cet angle là j'aurais j'aurais
validé à 200 % là la recette de
d'enfance oui bien sûr que c'est sympa
mais aujourd'hui des des livres de
cuisine il y en a dans tous les sens et
je trouve un petit peu dommage que un
club sportif n'utilise pas justement ce
le côté sportif et sportif de haut
niveau pour pouvoir communiquer c'est
tout avant de vous donner la parole
ériic Bellon parce que vous allez
intervenir sur cette première thématique
on profite de vous avoir en visio Pierre
Chevalier qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
moi je suis perplexe sur le principe sur
les raisons sur le timing euh je
prendrai le mot simplement recette qui a
plusieurs qui a plusieurs significations
recette de cuisine est-ce qu'ils ont
besoin de recette par ailleurs je ne
crois pas c'est c'est je suis je suis
étonné par le par le procédé c'est vrai
que des des livres de recettes de
cuisine on a l'impression on a
l'habitude de d'en voir évidemment par
les chefs les grands chefs les nos
grands-mères ce genre ce genre de choses
et ceux qui sont dans le monde de la
gastronomie et Dieu sait que c'est un
pilier de la de la culture française
une équipe de football je suis plus
perplexe sur la sur la raison principale
et ce qui les motive maintenant après
Grégory la la la rappeler c'est c'est
sans doute un bon concept marketing pour
faire un peu plus parler de de du PSG
après en ce moment il y a tellement de
sujets pour parler du PSG sportivement
que c'est presque j'ai presque
l'impression que c'est pour noyer le
poisson pour parler gastronomie
notamment et et pour pour éloigner de
certains sujets comme actuellement bon
le les résultats sportifs notamment en
Ligue des Champions le le problème du
stade entre le Parc des Princes et le
Stade de France il y a plein de sujets
c'est je suis je suis étonné par le
procédé encore une fois bon on en parle
aujourd'hui au moins ça leur fait ça le
fait de la pub Grégory très rapidement
avant é rappeler la démarche entre
guillemets gastronomique qui est puisque
il y a le chef David Toutin qui a
participé qui en fait s'est inspiré des
recettes que lui livraient les joueurs
pour pour les redessiner voilà et pour
les offrir au au lecteurs et l'aspect
nutritionnel n'a pas été totalement
aussi éludé parce queil y a Juan José
Moras voilà je parle portugais espagnol
spécialiste latine latin latino sur les
langues latine qui donne son avis sur
les recettes donc il y a une petite
analyse à chaque fois nutritionnelle
parce qu'on sait que la nutrition c'est
au cœur de la vie des sportifs de ha
niveau Éric bon qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez et Ben et ben nouveau livre de
cuisine c'est vrai que assez inattendu
d'avoir des recettes qui viennent des J
joueur du PSG c'est vrai que j'ai pas un
truc que j'avais
imaginé bah si ça permet à à des
familles et des
gamins de manger mieux moi je suis assez
d'accord que ça peut être un axe le foot
c'est tellement porteur et après je sais
pas est-ce qu'il y a des recettes
déshydraté pour les marins en course pas
regarder tout le livre malheureusement
mais ça
m'étonnerait on pense jamais à nous
justement en mer qu'est-ce que vous
mangez tout le monde se pose la question
euh pas des choses très
intéressantes c'est souvent de la
nourriture déshydratée ou alors dans des
conserves souple ça s'améliore de mieux
en mieux mais bon on attend surtout la
terre pour bien manger vous n'allez pas
faire de livre de
cuisine oh là là alors si je faisais un
livre de cuisine déjà je crois que ça
ferait hurler ma famille tout entier
hurler de rire évidemment parce que
c'est pas enfin je suis pas très grand
cuisinier et en revanche j'ai une femme
Marie qui elle est un vrai cordon bleu
donc si je faisais un livre de cuisine
je pense que j'en entendrai parler
pendant des
année alors si vous voulez en tout cas
vous procurer le livre pour Noël he
pourquoi pas ou un autre événement il
est disponible au prix de
24,95 € chez les éditions enha voilà si
vous voulez Yan pierre Éric ou vous
Grégory alors nous allons maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler du
plaisir Rugby Club l'équipe a perdu pour
la seconde fois la saison contre orsé on
reviendra également sur la défaite
d'ouille au 7e tour de la Coupe de
France contre Angers mais avant de
parler de ces thèmes on va parler de la
Transat
[Musique]
jacquesevabre donc commencer par la
Transa jaces Vabre deux iinois ont
participé à la compétition chez les
imoka Louis Burton originaire de la
selle lesbord sur bureau valallé le
versaill Erric Bellon sur stand as one
on va commencer par vous Éric bon la
course ne s'est pas très bien déroulée
euh ne s'est pas déroulé exactement
comme prévu vous avez abandonné ce
mercredi 8 novembre à 8h44 précise suite
à une avarie une liste s'est décollé à
l'avant du bateau euh Stan as one alors
vous êtes reparti vers roskov en
Bretagne pour réparer les dégâts moins
de 24 heures après le départ euh ériic
c'était un coup dur j'imagine
ah bah ouais ça c'est un vrai coup dur
c'est faut imaginer on travaille depuis
des mois depuis depuis des années pour
euh pas pour cette course mais bon pour
participer à ce genre d'événements il y
a une grande course dans l'année et nous
on a fait 24 heures c'est un peu comme
si vous avez un un 100 m des Jeux
Olympiques et vous êtes en finale et
puis vous cassez la gueule dans les
starting box c'est c'est horrible mais
c'est quelque chose pour lequel on peut
rien faire malheureusement la la la
tempête qui était là juste quelques
jours auparavant à à amener beaucoup de
bois beaucoup de branches beaucoup
d'arbresoup beaucoup de débris dans la
mer et on a vra touché un débris à
grande donc voilà un peu comme ça ça
fait un grand trou dans la coque et nous
la spécificité c'est que ça a endommagé
la structure du bateau fa savoir que nos
bateaux c'est un peu comme des œufs
c'estàd que quand les saisis en entier
ils sont très solides très rigides mais
quand on les
poinçonne sur un côté quand on appuie
juste sur un côté et il se casse donc
c'est à la fois très fragile et très
solide et voilà donc c'est horrible
parce que pour toute l'équipe tous les
partenaires tous ceux qui ont travaillé
ça s'est arrêté bien trop tôt Gregor
vous aviez une question oui bah erriic a
utiliser le le mot horrible on peut tout
à fait le le comprendre d'autant qu'on
va peut-être en parler c'était un projet
avec un bateau qu'il avait coconstruit à
lui-même avec notamment Jean Leca moi ma
question c'est plus il a parlé de la
tempête et c'est vrai qu'il y a eu des
conditions particulières le départ de la
transate a été retardé vous deviez
partir à la base le 29 octobre et
finalement le le départ n'a eu lieu que
le 7 novembre mais comment comment vous
l'avez vécu aussi ce moment on a compris
horrible au moment donc pour au moment
de de l'avarie mais le fait de
d'attendre dans le port du Havre ce ce
départ on ne savait pas vraiment quand
vous alliez pouvoir partir comment vous
l'avez vécu
bah j'ai dit au revoir deux fois à ma
fille je suis rentré trois fois donc
voilà ça ça résume un peu voilà on s'est
on s'est préparé une fois et moi on
était habillé toute l'équipe avait
démarré le mode du bateau était prêt à
partir et on nous a dit non non vous
partez pas et on sait pas quand vous
partez donc on a attendu une semaine
alors que tout est prêt faut savoir
qu'on est une équipe au moment du départ
on est au bord de la rupture on a mis
toute l'énergie qu'on avait qu'on avait
en en stock et on est prêt à partir donc
rester une semaine de plus déjà tout le
monde est sur les genoux donc on on est
resté une semaine on a pris la tempête
plein dans la gueule au port du Havre
donc il a fallu préserver nos bateaux
et on est enfin parti et et là dans les
restes de la tempête et ben moi ma
course s'est arrêtée je suis pas le seul
on est six bateaux six imoka et C arrêé
et il y a une dizaine de bateaux qui ont
pas pu partir dans cette course donc
voilà heureusement d'autres sont passés
et heureusement d'autres ont écrit une
belle histoire Pierre Chevalier vous
aviez une question vous aussi oui une
question pour compléter celle de celle
de Greg la la Course au Large est une
est une discipline extrêmement difficile
extrêmement exigeante et je je trouve
que vous avez un rôle de témoin de
témoin sur sur la santé de la planète
générale et est-ce qu'avec votre
expérience vous avez constaté que le par
exemple la Course au Large est plus
difficile les transates plus difficiles
du al peut-être au réchauffement
climatique ou aux différentes tempête
mais est-ce qu'il a est-ce qu'il y a
plus de justement plus de difficultés
quand on part comme ça pour 15 jours ou
plusieurs mois sur le vent des
globes alors je suis pas climatologue je
suis pas météorologue mais c'est vrai
que je m'y intéresse de près et quand on
est skippper de la course au large on
s'intéresse beaucoup aux événements
climatiques puisque si on était une
formule 1 les événements climatiques la
météo c'est notre moteur euh donc on
s'intéresse forcément à notre moteur moi
ce que j'observe depuis quelques années
c'est que il y a de plus en plus
d'événements euh météorologiques
violents donc des tempêtes violentes et
des tempêtes tôt en saison euh qui
devraiit être en fait des tempêtes que
que j'ai généralement on expériment en
janvier février et là cette tempête B on
se l' tapé en octobre donc voilà est-ce
que ça a un lien je sais pas mais voilà
ce que je ressens et c'est vrai que
toutes les transates que j'ai fait pour
l'instant on a des alisé C vent
réguliers normalement qui sont absents
et des tempêtes très importantes qui qui
se suivent et se suivent et se suivent
il du jarier vous qui êtes un grand fan
de voile pas de question pour vous
pourant bien sûr moi j'ai pas vous éc a
atttion j'écoute avec attention parce
que voilà pour moi les navigateurs sont
les derniers avec les les participants
du Dakar juste pour vous informer ériic
bon il suivait votre trajectoire et
celle de Louis hein quasiment tous les
jours bon là pour le coup rapide mais en
général il vous suit tout le temps en
général j'ai pas compris quand j'ai vu
le bateau qui est reparté dans l'autre
sens le premier matin quand j'ai quand
j'ai ouvert mon téléphone je dis mais
qu'est-ce qui se passe voilà je j'avoue
que là j'ai eu un bug et euh mais voà
Gén c'est la première chose c'est la
première chose que je fais le matin en
me réveillant quand il y a une course au
large je regarde où sont les positions
de nos de nos ivelinois et du coup c'est
c'est là vient ma question comment en
étant en partant de Versailles on se
retrouve justement navigateur sur sur ce
genre de d'épreuve puisque Ben à part la
à part la pièo des Suisses ou le grand
canal ben c'est vrai que pour faire du
bateau sur versaill c'est quand même pas
ce qu'il y a de plus de plus évident ah
j'ai j'ai ramé sur le Grand Canal
D6 c'est plutôt interdit mais le grand
canal j'ai ramé ouais euh ben en fait il
y a une librairie rue de Montreuil dans
le quartier saint-sfien à versaill dans
lequel j'ai j'ai rendu le libraire
totalement fou parce que je lui
demandais deux fois par semaine un livre
de mer parce que j'étais obsédé par ça
et je suis pas d'une famille de marins
ou alors il y a des marins il y a très
longtemps mais moi je sais pas
inconsciemment je me suis dit tiens
c'est sur la la mer que vont les les
vrais hommes les hommes à part entière
jeis pas j'ai grandi avec cette idée-là
et j'ai voulu j'ai toujours été attiré
par ça et donc voilà c'est par la
littérature que je suis arrivé à faire
ce métier de marin donc donc c'est une
ouais c'est une passion mais toute jeune
mais ouais c'est ça la question c'est
d'où vient cette comment est-ce qu'elle
est comment est-ce qu'elle est arrivée
parce que en effet moi vous m'auriez dit
j'allais en vacances l'été en Bretagne
et en effet j'ai fait les stages de
voile j'aurais pu comprendre quoi mais
là non c'est même pas c'est pas le cas
c'est c'est c'est incroyable et c'est un
super parcours quoi ben ouais en fait
c'est par le rêve c'est par le rêve et
et et je ouais vraiment par la lecture
de de ces livres j'ai j'ai j'ai lu les
les grands les grands classique les de
ces grands aventuriers tous les
pionniers qui ont créé ce sport et à 15
ans nous on les nos parents ils
nousemmenaient plutôt en camping-car à
la voile donc a un moment le camping-car
était devenu un peu petit pour un AD de
15 ans avec sa famille et j'ai eu la
chance d'avoir des copains dont les
parents avaient un bateau et je suis
allé Naver avec eux et j'ai vu que ça me
plaisait et en fait toute ma vie je l'ai
consacré après à ça aller faire du
bateau toujours plus loin et toujours
plus
vite au niveau de la course on va on va
revenir à ces à ces courses au large il
y aura notamment le vent des globes
l'année prochaine qu'est-ce que ça
change pour vous cet abandon au bout de
de 24 heures pour ce vend desglobes
euh bah ça ça change rien dans le la
qualification parce que moi je suis
assuré d'être sur le départ du vent des
globes parce que j'ai un bateau neuf euh
ça
change ça change des choses dans ma
préparation technique parce que
remplacer deux transat en terme
d'expérience c'est très compliqué donc
je vais manquer
d'expérience sur mon bateau il va
falloir que j'aille chercher d'autres
navigations d'aller naviguer encore plus
fort que ce que je pensais l'année
prochaine pour me préparer en revanche
il y a un point positif parce que moi je
suis câblé comme ça j'essaie de trouver
des choses positives à toutes les les
problèmes et c'est que je me suis rendu
compte à quel point je déteste l'abandon
c'est la première fois que j'ai
abandonné de ma vie et il est pas
question que je réabandonne donc je sais
que je vais me donner encore plus de
moyens maintenant pour préparer le mieux
possible mon bateau et me préparer le
mieux possible pour surtout surtout que
ça recommence pas je précise que ça sera
votre 2ème vent des globes vous aviez
terminé le premier vent des globes sur
lequel vous aviez participé grégoryi
vous vouliez poser une question sur le
bateau je crois oui sur le bateau
puisque on là qu'on a commencé à
l'évoquer tout à l'heure c'est un bateau
bah qui a été justement construit par
par Eric avec Jean-Le cam et David
raison justement pour le vent des globes
et il y a eu un choix fort qui a été
fait sur le bateau quand on voit voilà
c'est un peu le dictate de la vitesse
ces courses à la voile avec ses foiles
qui donnent l'impression de faire
léviter les les bateaux sur la mer vous
avez fait le choix justement vous de ne
pas prendre de feuill de pas mettre de
feuill mais plutôt des des dérives
droites juste pour ceux qui connaissent
pas le le monde de la VO qu'est-ce que
ça change concrètement et pourquoi vous
avez fait ce
choix le on a fait un choix raisonnable
et avec Jean Lecam on s'est posé cette
question de quoi a-t-on réellement
besoin pour être performant sur le vent
des globes et on sa'est on s'est tourné
vers les faits on a vu que sur le
dernier vent des globes les bateaux à
dérive droite c'estd les bateaux qui
restent dans l'eau qui ne volent pas pas
au-dessus de l'eau et ben en fait aller
aussi vite sur le vent des globes que
les bateaux à foil les bateaux à foil
c'est une solution
technique extrême ça fait des images
extraordinaires de bateau qui volent
au-dessus de l'eau mais pour un homme
tout seul autour du monde avec tous les
problèmes que ça engendre les problèmes
techniques les problèmes de charge les
problèmes de survitesse et bien les
bateau à des rives droite en fait ont
toute leur chance et si on met ça
euh avec le fait que ces bateaux coûtent
deux fois moins cher qui sont beaucoup
plus fiables qui nous permettent d'aller
naviguer plus
longtemps plus souvent et ben
ah je crois qu'on vous a perdu Éric
béion la connexion dans le finister
n'est pas très bonne apparemment alors
on va quand même parler de notre deuxème
evelinois Louis Burton qui s'est classé
à la 16e place il a terminé la course ce
mardi 21 novembre à à 16h58 il nous
avait envoyé une petite vidéo pendant la
traversée on regarde et on espère
retrouver juste après éic Bellon salut
les ivlines salut salut bienvenue à
bordb Vallé al vous voyez des vies à
moitié nu parce que il s'est fait passer
dessus par une vague voilà tout va bien
on est sorti des îles
Canaris on a on a remonté quelques
places depuis notre palité depuis le
départ et puis maintenant on arrive dans
l'alysée caractéristique de laalisée il
y a du vent
fa beau chaud ça va vite et le bateau va
vite exaement penseon pour le moner
l'extérieur on va aller voir dehors
attention c'est que je mee pas tremper
aussi le bateau
VO quand Mme pas
mal avec des
pointes
28 29 de c'est très
rapide donc j'espère que ça vous plaît
nous on va bientôt voir les premiers
poissons volants aura des images à
bientôt on a retrouvé ériic Béon et on a
pu profiter de cette magnifique vidéo de
Louis Burton ériic bon qu'est-ce que
vous avez pensé de la course de de Louis
Burton il est arrivé du coup en en 16e
position vous avez un peu
suivi bah ouis ouais j'ai j'ai j'ai
suivi alors je vais être honnête pas
d'une façon assidue parce que ces images
me rendent très jaloux donc et pendant
de semaines j'ai essayé de réparer mon
bateau donc j'étais plutôt avec la
meleuse la colle et essayer d'organiser
le retour sur l'eau mais oui ils sont
bien battus c'est des bons David et
Louis ils sont ils ont fait déjà un
départ canon
un peu trop canon d'ailleurs et donc non
c'est une belle course bien sûr ils ont
ils ont choisi une option qui a pas
forcément payé mais en tout cas ils sont
arrivés de l'autre côté c'était bien
parce que ça ça permet aussi de rassurer
lui sur ses capacités de de grand marin
donc je suis très content pour lui très
content pour au de y jier vous qui les
avez suivi qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
de de cette course moi je suis content
de pouvoir en discuter avec Eric moi
j'ai j'ai pas compris donc il était dans
dans la dans la partie sud de la de la
course et et d'un seul coup n'a pas tout
regardé apparemment c'est pas grave je
quand même expliquer du coup et d'un
seul coup on a vu il est allé rejoindre
ceux qui étaient sur le nord et je me
suis dit bah oui peut-être que ça va
payer sur la sur la suite mais
globalement ben ça n'a pas chambouler le
ça va pas chambouler le classement et ça
m'a paru vraiment bizarre de le voir
tout seul prendre reprendre à droite
pour aller rechercher le deuxième Ploton
qui était qui était un peu plus sonore
est-ce
que est-ce que c'est le genre de
décision que Louis est capable de faire
parce que est-ce que en effet sur V Glob
il est aussi capable de prendre des
options que personne va aller chercher
ou est-ce que c'est quelque chose que
vous aussi vous auriez pu envisager à un
moment à un moment ou un autre euh
ouais alors on sait jamais ce qu'on fait
sur l'eau faut faut être vraiment dans
le dans la décision pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir avoir un critique dessus euh
ouais je pense que toute façon il y il y
avait dès le départ il y avait deux
choix à faire soit fallait la prendre la
face nord qui était la face la plus
ardue avec du vent fort avec du prê
c'estàdire du vent de face la mer de
face et et tout le monde savait qu'il y
allait avoir une grosse dépression qui
allait être sur une grosse tempête
devant le sur le chemin donc il fallait
être armé pour et se dire ok je vais au
combat il y avait une option Sud qui
était déjà moins payante mais avec les
vagues dans le bon sens et le vent dans
le bon sens donc quand on est au début
d'une transate on se dit vaut mieux
arriver de l'autre côté c'est le
vainqueur c'est celui qui arrive donc je
pense que lui il a dû se dire bon bah je
je fonce avec le les vagues dans le bon
sens et le vent dans le bon sens et je
pense que ces logiciels ils ont dû lui
montrer que en fait ça allait vraiment
pas payer et qu'à un moment donné il
fallait raccrocher avec les gens du Nord
qui avaient choisi la face nord mais le
courage paye toujours et c'est ceux qui
ont décidé d'y aller avant qui de toute
façon était gagnant donc il a essayé de
se raccrocher et gagner quelques places
avec les gens qui poursuiv au sud mais
ça pouvait pas gagner plus ok Grégory
canal qu'est-ce que vous en pensezv de
la course de Louis Burton bah au-delà du
classement 16e qui peut peut-être nous
laisser sur notre fin quand on connaî
ces capacités moi je pense que le vrai
point positif dans cette course c'est
qu'il l'a terminé parce queon se
souvient que sur les deux dernières
grosses courses Louis Burton avait en
compagnie Davy Bodard avait ils avaient
dématté et du coup ils avaient dû
abandonner c'est aussi une situation
alors c'est pas exactement la même
situation que qu'Eric il est aussi sur
un nouveau bateau mais qu'il n'a pas
construit hein au contraire Deric c'est
un bateau qui avait fait le dernier vent
des globes et qu' l' a racheté bah là
voilà l'idée d'ici ce vent des globes
c'est bah de se faire la main en quelque
sorte sur ce nouveau bateau il y avait
il avait été contraint à l'abandon dans
les deux dernières grosses courses donc
là au moins il termine cette course et
ça c'est le gros point positif à retenir
petit point négatif c'est qu'encore une
fois il a écopé d'une une pénalisation
comme au au vent des globes pour avoir
été trop rapide au départ erriic le
disait assez de manière assez
humoristique ouais il a envie d'y aller
à chaque fois Louis Burton euh Pierre
Chevalier qu'est-ce que
ouais une une question sous forme de
question pour pour ériic dernière
question après il faudra libérer Eric ok
de béoien de de de la course au au large
comment se font les les choix de
catégorie c'est quel qu'est-ce qui guide
les choix entre imoka et ultime par
exemple est-ce que c'est des questions
de budget ou est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
raisons qui qui guident votre
choix Ben l'imoka est le bateau qui fait
le vent des globes donc tous ceux et
celles qui ont un imoka aujourd'hui et
qui sont dans dans cette catégorie et en
fait il y a qu'une envie c'est de faire
le vent des globes toutes les courses
sont là pour nous préparer au vent des
globes qui a lieu tous les 4 ans et qui
est notre coupe du monde à nous donc
voilà les ultimes eux sont beaucoup plus
nombreux beaucoup plus moins pardon
beaucoup moins nombreux ils sont 5 ou 6
ça dépend des fois et c'est des
budgets 5 si fois plus importants avec
des courses beaucoup moins populaires
que le vend des globes donc après c'est
des d'autres choix c'est des bateaux
extraordinaires qui volent pour eux pour
le pour le coup il volent vraiment sur
sur l'eau et voilà mais c'est sûr que
quand on veut faire le V des globes on
va on a un imoka et on va sur le circuit
imoka et on retrouvera la plupart des
des skippers d'ultime sur le sur les
imoka en vend desgobes non non non ben
dans les dans les les skippers d'ultime
vous avez deux anciens vainqueurs du
vent des globes qui sont François gabar
et Armel leclage qui a gagné là la
Transat jaabre euh donc certains quand
ils ont gagné le vent des globes passent
en ultime c'estàd qu'ils vont avec une
monture plus grande plus chè plus rapide
merci à vous Éric Bellon on va vous
libéré on vous voulez au moins 20
minutes sur l'émission je crois qu'on
l'a légèrement dépassé merci en tout cas
d'avoir joué le jeu le prochain grand
rendez-vous pour vous ce sera les le
vent des globes 2024 on continuera
évidemment à vous suivre vous et on
continuera suivre Louis Burton nos deux
iinois Merci à VOUS Éric Bellon alors on
portez-vous bien
salut parler football et de la Coupe de
France c'était le match des grands jours
à ouille pour ce 7e tour de la Coupe de
France le club local pensionnaire de R1
recevait les professionnels d'Anger ce
samedi 18 novembre une équipe qui évolue
en Ligue 2 après 45 minutes très
équilibré sur un terrain humide ce sont
finalement les visiteurs qui ouvrent le
score grâce à lois dinny 1-0 ce sera le
score encore la pause en seconde période
où il n'abdique pas tant d'égalisé se
procure des situations mais ce sont
finalement les engevins qui font le
break à la 90e minute suite à ce penalty
2 à0 on va peut-être le voir à l'image
la logique a été respectée ce samedi sur
cette pelouse ivelinoise on écoute les
réactions bah on peut être fier de ce
qu'on a ce qu'on a fait on joue contre
une division qui a 5 niveaux auudessus
du nutre je m'attendais à une victoire
je m'attendais une victoire peu importe
l'adversaire encore une fois je lu dis
sur un match il peut tout se passer
c'est aussi le charm de la la coupe de
France les les conditions nous étaient
favorables après voilà tout est dans
l'intensité et dans le réalisme
tactiquement techniquement c'est évident
que il y a une classe d'écart et et ça
se voit en tout cas lorsque nous sommes
sur le terrain maintenant aujourd'hui
avec de la volonté avec plein de choses
on a réussi à combler ces petits manques
et à montrer que sur 90 minutes on peut
essayer de
rivaliser la question sur cette
thématique peut-on d'être fier du
parcours de ouille dans cette Coupe de
France messieurs oui ou non vous votez
vous
hésitez oui évidemment mais pourquoi
alors allez au fond de votre pensé c'est
pas les mêmes c'est pas les mêmes
infrastructures c'est pas les mêm club
mais c'est vrai que Versailles il y a 2
ans nous a emmené jusqu'en demi-finale
de de Coupe de France donc aujourd'hui
ce qu'on veut c'est voir aussi donc ce
qui se passe plus bas on va dire
que'est pas important non ce qu'on veut
c'est que justement ou puisse aussi
briller alors la demiinale ce serait ce
serait là quelque chose d'inédit mais
voilà puisse avancer encore encore et
encore alors c'est vrai que c'est top de
perdre contre un club de Ligue 2 mais
mais c'est vrai que bah ouais on a été
en fait on est gourmand du fait que on a
eu mieux il y a 2 ans voilà c'est tout
Pierre Chevalier est-ce que vous aussi
vous voulez avoir à nouveau du caviar
pour savourer un parcours en Coupe de
France toujours toujours tant que tant
que Grégory canalet ne prédira pas des
victoires au final ça veut dire qu'on il
faudra qu'on attende encore j'avais
prédit l'élimination de ouille je
précise alors je précise aussi que ang
est 2è de Ligue 2 donc
logiquement 2è de Ligue 2 R1 pour
rouille c'est là là Gregor a
raison là les bras Monon les bras Monon
maintenant on va demander les les paris
les paris à à Greg c'est le charme de la
coupe le charme de la Coupe de France et
et évidemment on a suffisamment
d'équipes dans les iveline pour pouvoir
avoir des avoir de de belles aventures
effectivement versaill nous l'a donné il
y a de
an on voit d'ailleurs que les lesis les
saisons se suivent et ne se ressemblent
pas dans tous les sports et et
c'est c'est c'est oui c'est c'est
dommage fier oui parce qu'ils sont allés
le plus loin possible cette saison
voilà et et ils sont ils sont à quatre
divisions
d'écart par rapport à par rapport à
anger voilà logique respecté al là c'est
tous les poncifs du du football et la
Coupe de France logique respecté et puis
et puis ce charme de coupe qui qui ne
verra pas cette saison un poussé un
petit poussé supplémentaire dans les
ivelines greégoryi qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ben je pense qu'on peut être fier
oui déçu en revanche là je rejoins
totalement Yan et surtout sur le déroulé
du match pendant une bonne partie de la
rencontre où il y a fait jeu égal avec
les les Angevins vous l'avez rappelé 2e
de Ligue 2 il y a quatre divisions
d'écart entre entre les deux il y a même
eu un but un moment refusé pour une
position d'or jeu tout le monde s'est
levé et finalement bah le le but a été
refusé et ce qui laisse aussi un peu sur
sur sur ma fin ce qui me laisse sur ma
fin c'est ce premier but en juin qui
arrive juste avant la première période
on on est aux alentours de la 40e minute
de jeu et c'est une mais entente entre
le gardien et et ses défenseurs donc
voilà il y a peut-être il y avait
peut-être un petit peu de pression mais
c'est dommage au vu des faits du match
et finalement bah Angé n'a inscrit son
deuxième but qu'à la toute fin du match
sur sur penalty c'est dommage que et
bien les joueurs de ouille n'ont pas
comment dire créer un peu plus la
surprise créer un peu plus d'exploit et
essayer d'emmener anger dans dans S
retranchement l'autre réussite de ce
match alors c'est ça c'était pas une
réussite mais il y a une vraie réussite
c'est qu' y avait quand même 2000
spectateurs dans ce stade Maurice Baquet
de ou avec des conditions on l'a vu
assez assez difficile il y avait on
félicite d'ailleurs les dirigeants qui
ont organisé un super match de Coupe de
France parce que moment il était déc
peut-être prévu d'aller jouer à anger
anger était prêt à les recevoir ils ont
pu finalement organiser ce match à ou
donc du coup stade plein même si
effectivement les conditions n'étaient
pas au rendez-vous et bon oui déçu aussi
parce que
c'était déjà ici assez loin Coupe de
France 32e de finale 32e de finale en
2018 ils avaient perdu contre conarne
ils vont pas récidiver mais bon on peut
être quand même fier
d'eux petit bémol sur la sur la
publicité sur la qualité des
infrastructures des Yvelines là on sait
que vu les la pluviométrie qu'il y a eu
qu'il y a eu c'était déjà bien pouvoir
recevoir ce match mais finalement ça
fait ça donne un terrain qui est qui est
à la limite du praticable bon ça ça
désavantage les deux équipes donc de
toute façon façon c'est c'est c'était
bien d'avoir quand même un un stade
plein autour d'une piscine peut-être
d'un terrain de foot petit coup de
gueule peut-être pour vous du côté du
penalty Grégory canalé avec cette
pananka qui a ét marqué en fin de match
à la 90e minute par les ang 20 Abdelli
qui a marqué sur penalty donc qui est
venu inscrire le sais pas si on peut
revoir le penalty à Z0 je sais pas si on
va pouvoir le le voir mais en tout cas
c'est vrai que moi j'ai trouvé euh voilà
c'est quand même
une équipe de Ligue 2 qui vient
affronter le petit Pousset ça doit être
une grande fête et là il y a ce penalty
à la fin de match je sais pas si on va
pouvoir le voir et le joueur Abdelli
danger s'est dit bah pourquoi pas faire
aller une petite panen histoire histoire
voilà histoire d'humilier d'enfoncer
totalement les joueurs de ouille et
d'humilier le gardien de ver j'ai trouvé
le geste assez bas voilà c'était pas
très classe pour pour terminer un match
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez pas il y a
plus d'en jeu quoi il mè déjà zé en
effet on peut le jouer de manière plus
classe et du coup faire un vrai un vrai
tir au penalty avec le risque ben que le
gardien l'arrête mais ça n'aurait pas
changé de toute façon la le le le le jeu
là c'est vrai comme tu dis la Panenka
c'est un peu
ouais c'est c'est pas un beau geste
c'est pas un beau geste on l'avait pas
visibleement mais pas mais mais c'était
une panenka on peut revoir le résumé du
match sur la page Youtube de tv78 alors
ou il a réalisé quand même un beau
parcours ils ont éliminé éan ils ont
éliminé Linas monleri un spécialiste de
de cette Coupe de France au 5e tour cour
courouronne au 4e tour r M maison au 3è
tour qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous
Grégory notamment Linas Moni he qui qui
était un spécialiste de cette Coupe de
France affrontter le parisain-germain
qui avait déjà éliminé une équipe de
Ligue 1 c'était il me semble si je dis
pas de bêtis je me demande si c'était
pas anger à l'époque qu'ils avaient
éliminé déjà Linas monerry a vérifié en
tout
casit jusqu'en 32e ils avaient fait un
énorme mat match devant 15000
spectateurs face au parisintgermain bon
ils avaient pris une une valise à la fin
mais voilà d'être là donc oui parcours
honorable mais il manque quand même ce
ce comment dire il manque cet adversaire
de Aang et ça aurait pu être
effectivement anger voilà il manque il
manque cette magie de la Coupe de France
du du petit poussé qui sort un gros ils
ont sorti Linas meri qui évolu une
division a-dessus effectivement en
National 3 mais on aurait voulu voir
peut-être un club professionnel échouer
face à face à ou alors ou devra
maintenant se reconcentré sur le
championnat de R1 les ibinois occupent
pour l'instant la 9e place du classement
après 6 journées disputées on va
maintenant parler rugby je vous vois
sourire Pierre Chevalier dans le
championnat de fédéral 2 plaisir c'est
incliné 31 28 sur sa pelouse dans le
choc de cette poule contre ors lors de
la 8e journée c'est la deuxè défaite du
club cette saison au classement plaisir
est toujours premier mais le club ne
compte que deux points d'avance sur
l'ureux et orsé versaill est 8e et le
mlgp est 9e la question sur cette
thématique le club de plaisir va-t-il
monter cette saison oui ou non quand on
voit le début de saison de plaisir on va
peut-être voir le le classement déjà
pour vous faire une petite idée voilà on
voir le classement qui s'affiche plaisir
34 points Leureux 32 orsé 32 Saint-Malo
31 jeuneviler 24 donc on voit déjà qu'il
y a un petit fossé qui s'est crée avec
le le 5e euh qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez alors pour vous vous êtes mitigé
à
Gregory oui pour
oui vousali ou ou alors pourquoi Grégor
pourquoi vous êtes partagé on Dona
ensuite la parole à Yan et ensuite à
Pierre bah parce qu'on est on a joué
journées on est encore très loin alors
certes plaisir a fait un très bon début
de saison même si sur les deux dernières
semaines ils ont collectionneré bah
leurs deux seules défaites de la saison
deux
défaites d'affilé et surtout bah pierre
le dira très bien parce que lui est
spécialiste de cette discipline il y a
deux championnats en fait il y a une
première phase régulière où
effectivement s pl plaisir se qualifie
dans dans dans dans ces phases finales
euh aura réussi déjà un premier objectif
d'ailleurs c'est l'objectif qui qu'ils
se sont fixés en début de saison c'est
de pouvoir se qualifier pour les les
phases finales de fédéral 2 et après
c'est un autre championnat en fait donc
c'est c'est compliqué de se projeter
peut-être qu'après 6 ans passés en
fédéral 2 il y a l'expérience ENF
nécessaire pour pour pouvoir espérer
monter en fédéral une mais je pense
qu'il est encore trop tôt pour se dire
si oui plaisir pourra le faire ils en
ont les capacités après est-ce qu'ils
pourront le faire ça c'est la question
qui reste à élucider yerier qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez voilà la même chose
alors le
bloup on a fait un/ers du championnat il
il y a 12 équipes donc en 22 matchs on
est à 8 donc on a fait un tiers du
un/ers seulement et par contre là où ça
aurait pu être différent c'est sils
avent pas perdu les deux derniers matchs
ça veut dire que au niveau numérique il
serait quand même bien bien au-delà et
là on pourrait se dire bah oui perdu la
7è journée à 19 à 16 contre jeune Villet
donc c'était quand même assez serré hein
c'est des scores serrés à chaque fois
c'est des Scor serré mais ça n'empêche
que c'est de la défaite alors on prend
un point parce qu'on a le bonus défensif
mais euh c'est pas c'est pas la victoire
à quatre c'est pas la victoire à quatre
points euh maintenant ce que l'on peut
dire c'est que ils ont quasi atteint euh
le premier objectif qui est la
qualification pour pour les phases
finales puisque il y aura six clubs six
clubs qualifiés euh et là bah comme on
l'a vu il y a un trou avec le 5e
normalement ça devrait bien se passer
pour pour pour pour pour cette pour
cette pour ce premier objectif après
l'objectif de cette saison pour plaisir
c'est de terminer aux deux premières
places c'est une qualification qu' y a
une phase de barrage auà de la deè place
ou les deux premiers pour l'instant
c'est normal que à la 8e journée les
deux premières places du championnat ne
soient pas encore encore défini mais
ballotage favorable puisqu'ils sont
premiers du championnat et que bah ça
s'est plutôt bien passé il va falloir
remettre le gouvernaille dans le bon
sens pour pour pour les prochains pour
les prochains matchs tout simplement
Pier chevalier qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez alors bien placé pour voilà bien
placé pour pouvoir en parler parce que
donc notre équipe versaillaise est pour
la 2uxèe année consécutive dans la poule
de dans la poule de plaisir je prendrai
le passé et pr plir de les avoir ou pas
c'est tout ça fait toujours plaisir ça
fait toujours très plaisir de les avoir
parce que parce que c'est là sur cette
saison de Fédérale 2 on a trois trois
équipe des ivelines euh donc passer
passer et présent pour plaisir ça fait 7
7 saisons 8 saisons que que plaisir est
en fédéral 2 qui construit son construit
son projet justement sur le long terme
avec depuis deux saisons l'objectif
annoncé de la montere en fédéral une
nous petit pousser versailla qui sommes
dans cette pou que depuis de saisons
maintenant la deuxème saison on mesure à
quel point comme je disais tout à
l'heure les les saisons se suivent et ne
se ressemble pas avec des difficultés à
des difficultés à surmonter on en
parlera peut-être mais pour
plaisir le le passé c'est ce qu'on ce
qu'on ce qu'ils ont construit dans la
dans la durée et en profondeur sur la
structuration du club qui donne un
groupe en plus avec un recrutement a
priori ciblé bien senti sur cette saison
un groupe de qualité et qui a la
maturité en gros c'est le passé a donné
ça c'est c'est 7p saisons en fédéral 2
ont donné cette expérience là la
maturité nécessaire pour aller loin le
présent c'est ce que j'ai vu sur ce que
j'ai vu ou ce constater sur le sur le
début de saison vous l'avez tous rappelé
début de saison canon de de plaisir qui
met la main sur cette poule 8 de la
fédéral 2 on l'impression qu'ils
allaient s'envoler he finalement et pour
le coup pour les avoir pour les avoir
affronté on a pris une on a pris une
fessée on a pris une belle danse et qui
était totalement mérité il il y avait
pas pas photo sur le sur ce match là et
et puis effectivement la saison la
saison se passe et et on a là deux
défaites une contre jeun viler une
contre HSY à chaque fois de peu
effectivement il y a eu un démarrage
diesel à orsé où ils ont été mèés de de
plus de 20 points 21-0 je crois à la
mi-temps et pas zéro mais de 21 points
et et ça a été après plaisir est revenu
dans la partie donc il y a des
ressources aussi il y a des ressources
mais il y a aussi des failles il y a
sûrement des failles donc pour répondre
à la question est-ce que c'est est-ce
que plaisir va monter j'ai envie de dire
oui parce que bon c'est les evelines
même si on a encore des derby à jouer
hein bien sûr euh on leur rendra pas
forcément la la partie facile au f
contre versaill voilà par exemple par
exemple mais c'est c'est comparable au
trajet de courbeevie l'année dernière
qui a qui avait bien mené sa saison qui
a terminé dans les deux premiers donc
face qualificatif direct pour le les les
phases finales les deux premiers et
après les quatre les quatre
suivants se se joue en barrage pour
pouvoir après passer passer en en phase
finale et il y aura ce nouveau
Championnat qui démarrera mais je pense
que avec ce qui a été mis en place et
avec ce que ce qu'on a pu constater sur
ce début de saison c'est la c'est la
bonne saison je dirais pas la saison ou
jamais mais c'est la bonne saison pour
pour plaisir d'accéder d'accéder au
nirvana de la de la fééralune
NC si si on peut dire un petit mot très
rapide sur Versailles avant de passer à
la prochaine thématique parce qu'on
arrive déjà pratiquement à la fin de
cette émission versaill versaill début
de saison début de saison difficile on a
en fait les raisons principales c'est
que la vie d'un club amateur n'est pas
un long flu tranquille on a perdu en
fait on a perdu des cadres de la saison
dernière qui pour des raisons
professionnel personnel ont changé de
club voire arrêter le rugby et puis on
ne remplace pas un capitaine on ne
remplace pas des cadres et des leaders
de jeu aussi facilement que ça et donc
les nouvelles recrues se sont intégrées
dans le dans le dans le projet mais ben
là il y a il y a il y a un certain
nombre de fait de jeu la pièce qui qui
tombe pas dans le qui tombe pas du bon
côté des des choix et puis des un peu
comme l'équipe de France en ce moment un
jeu au pied défaillant avec des
conditions aussi qui qui sont difficiles
donc là on est on est un peu dans le dur
avec trois défaites d'affilé là et
notamment à la maison donc en pleine non
pas crise mais en pleine en pleine
réflexion pour corriger rapidement une
petite tempête he pour faire une
référence au Gon exactement et et a
assurer l'objectif majeur qui qui était
celui qui était annoncé ce qui était le
qui était le le maintien comme la saison
dernière après si on peut aller si on
peut aller grappiller une deuxème
qualification pour une deème année
consécutive évidemment on ne s'en
privera pas on vous souhaite bon courage
en tout cas pour pour cette fin de
saison enfin pour la suite de la saison
la prochaine journée de fédéral 2 est
programmé le 3 décembre prochain plaisir
jouera sur le terrain de Saint-Malo et
Versailles ira à oser à oser exactement
on va maintenant passer à notre page
[Musique]
débat on va passer à notre page débat et
surtout à l'envolé de grégoryi le moment
qu'on qu'on attend avec impatience et là
il arrive en fin d'émission donc tout le
monde s'est posé peut-être la question
s'il y allait avoir ou pas cet envolé il
y a cet envolé alors de quoi allez-vous
nous parler aujourd'hui Grégor je vais
essayer de vous faire rêver pour la fin
de cette émission en tout cas moi j'ai
des frissons quand j'entends
[Musique]
ça vous ne chantez pas Grégori ils sont
les meilleurs this inie Beston this are
the champions des paroles trilingues en
français en allemand et en anglais qui
raisonnent dans la tête de beaucoup de
passionnés de football beaucoup de
passionnés de sport en général l'y de la
Ligue des Champions la plus grande des
compétitions européennes dont la finale
est regardé chaque année par près de 400
millions de téléspectateurs quand il
rentrent sur le terrain plusieurs
joueurs l'ont dit ce qu'ils attendent le
plus c'est d'entendre que cette musique
légendaire composée par le britannique
Tony briton demmar moi moi même petit je
me rêvais à jouer la Ligue des Champions
rien que pour cette are galvanisant avec
le maillot de mon équipe de cœur la
Juventus bon finalement je n'avais pas
le niveau et de toute façon vous savez
mieux vous avez le plateau de tv78 j'ai
le plateau de tv78 de toute façon la
Juve cette année n'est même pas
qualifiée pour la Ligue des Champions ce
n'est pas grave des ivelinois ont la
chance ont eu cette chance de disputer
des matchs de la coupe aux grandes
oreilles c'est sont surnom et dernière
en date c'est Sikou niakateé le
défenseur central de 24 ans débutter le
football à l'âge de 6 ans du côté du FC
Saint-Germain dans les evelines il est
même passé un temps par la formation du
pariss-germain à l'été 2022
l'international malien a quitté le FC
mes où il était remplaçant en Ligue 2
pour le club de Braga au Portugal là le
joueur s'impose comme titulaire dans le
club qui va finir à la 3e place du
championnat portugais synonyme de
qualification au 3e tour des barrages
pour la Champions League finalement
Braga se qualifie et sikouakate découvre
la compétition 7 saison il a disputé
quatre matchs de son équipe tous comme
titulaires et a même marqué un but
contre l'Union Berlin lors de la 2e
journée le rêve devient alors réalité
quand le défenseur fait face au grand
Real Madrid contre lui Modric Cruz
Bellingham Rodrigo ou encore Vinicius
junior au final ce sont deux défaites
pour lui ebraga face aux Espagnols
vainqueur on le rappelle à 14 reprises
de la Ligue des Champions mais ce sont
surtout des souvenirs plein la tête pour
ce jeune eV no c'est exceptionnel je
prends un maximum de plaisir parce que
je ne sais pas si je revivrai ça un jour
dans ma carrière on va dire que j'étais
un peu dans le trou en France et
désormais je me frotte aux plus grands
attaquants du monde voici ce qu'il a
déclaré au journal L'Équipe si
kununakaté en tout cas bien raison
carpédiem cuueillir le jour sans se
soucier du lendemain car l'essentiel a
été accompli pour lui d'autres pépites
de notre territoire ont eu la chance
comme lui de vivre ce rêve éveillé de la
Ligue des Champions Matthéo gendouzi
notamment 24 ans milieu de terrain qui a
vécu à Verneuil sur scène qui a
découvert les joueurs de la Ligue des
Champions l'année dernière avec
l'Olympique de Marseille Michell je m'
souviens gendouzi disputera d'ailleurs
six matchs dans le tour principal avec
l'OM et marquera de buts puis pour
continuer de disputer cette très belle
compétition la plus belle des
compétitions européennes livelinois a dû
quitté la cité fosséenne cet été
direction l'Italie et la Lazio il a joué
quatre rencontres cette saison à chaque
fois en partant du banc des remplaçants
et comment ne pas citer un habitué de
cette compétition Kilian bappé avec ses
65 matchs disputés et ses 42 buts
inscrits c'est notre ivelinois
d'adoption Kyan Mbappé alors certes il
est originaire de la scène saint-onim
mais il a fait ses classes en étant
formé du côté de l'INF Claire Fontaine
il aussi un peu à nous et depuis 2017 il
s'est entraîné régulièrement à
Saint-Germain en lait et à poissi avec
son club du pariss saagermain à poissi
nouveau centre d'entraînement donc oui
qui est quand même un peu yvelinois le
débat est clos et c'est sans doute le
seul d'ailleurs parmi ceux que j'ai cité
qui a une réelle chance de remporter la
Ligue des Champions même si le
parissgermain s'y est souvent cassé les
dents il a frôlé la coupe aux grandes
oreilles en seissant jusqu'en finale de
l'édition 2020 car jouer la C1 c'est une
chose la remportter c'en est une autre
et je souhaite à Mbappé qu'il puisse
atteindre ce dou rêve et marcher dans
les pas d'un certain Nicolas Anelka et
oui on a peut-être tendance à l'oublier
en raison de ses frasques mais le
trapiste a bel et bien remporté la Ligue
des Champions en 2000 avec le Real
Madrid même si là on le voit avec les
couleurs du paris-germain c'était en
finale contre Valence l'attaquant 21 ans
à l'époque et titulaire au côté de
Fernando Morientes les madriilenes
l'emporteront 3 à0 et lors de cette
édition
1999-2000 Anelka inscrit deux buts et
non des moins importants un but dans
chacune des deux demi-finales disputé
face au Bayern Munich l'international
français jouera au cours de sa carrière
grâce à ses passages à Arsenal au Real
au PSG à fenerbaché à Chelsea ou encore
à la Juve 75 matchs de C1 pour un total
de 22 buts inscrits chapeau Nicolas
Anelka a montré la voie disputer la
Ligue des champion et même la gagné
quand le rêve devient
réalité j'avais envie qu'on la réentende
à la fin parce queme par une magnifique
musique magnifique moi en tout cas ça
met vraiment magnifique musique pour une
magnifique envolé à Grégor encore
on vous applaudit une nouvelle fois
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
envolé de de Grégory yen du
Jarrier je vais pas dire que c'est la
plus belle mais c'est vrai que c étit
une très belle envolée alors peut-être
moins actue en ce moment pour pouvoir
rebondir sur sur quelque chose mais
cakaté quand même joue avec Braga la
Ligue des Champions joue contre le Real
Madrid et là on se dit
mais c'est pas le premier quoi c'est pas
le premier joueur français qui et alors
après même je dirais dans d'autres
sports parce que je vais parler de de et
ben non je vais pas en parler mais de
notre double champion du monde de
cyclisme sur route qui pareil Julien la
Philippe voilà ça m'est revenu qui qui
qui était dans des dans des équipes
françaises et qui a dû aller en Belgique
pour pouvoir éclore et bien là c'est
pareil on a un bon joueur qui qui est
dans des clubs français et il est obligé
de s'expatrier au Portugal pour pouvoir
Ben se rendre il le dit lui-même j'étais
dans le creux on on ne faisait pas
confiance et là
boum les qualit les qualités sont là les
qualités sont là c'est c'est des euh des
des des des des connexions avec les
entraîneurs peut-être j'en suis
clairement mais en France on a quand
même les infrastructures pour préparer
les joueurs c'est quand même dommage
qu'on ne soit pas capable de les
détecter et de et de pouvoir en en bah
faire fructifier tout simplement parce
que cas mais oui ils ont niveau nos
joueur Pierre Chevalier qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez greégory a très bien très
bien rendu et restitué le souffle de la
Ligue des Champions quand on est fan de
sport cette compétition là elle est à
part surtout parce que aussi c'est le
footb football un un sport tellement
médiatique et médiatisé mais je trouve
qu'il y a systématiquement chaque année
quand la Ligue des Champions revient
cette espèce de de de trêve sur tout ce
sur tout ce qu'il y a autour il y a il y
a ce rêve et cette ce clincant de la de
la Ligue des champions qui qui qui
suscite vraiment toutes les toutes les
énergies toutes les envies toutes les
tous les souhaits et les rêves de
beaucoup de personnes les sportifs on
d'abord d'ailleurs mais aussi tous les
spectateurs donc c'est oui oui c'est
c'est un rendez-vous que greégory nous a
brillamment rappelé le le joueur
peut-être qui vous a plus marqué parmi
tous ceux qu'il a cité le genouur que
vous a affectionné le plus c'est celui
celui qui va qui va
marquer il NOTAM gouzipp le le problème
de enfin voilà quand on voit le parcours
de de de danelka on se dit oui en effet
purée il a gagné la Ligue des Champions
mais il y a eu tellement et moi ce qui
m'a ce qui m'a marqué c'est le nombre de
clubs que tu as pu annoncer et et là on
se dit il y a souci aujourd'hui Mbappé
il a 24 ans il a deux clubs et et et il
en fera peut-être que trois dans toute
sa carrière donc mais MPP ça viendra ça
viendra le seul le seul risque c'est que
ça ne vienne pas avec Paris et que de
toute façon il sera il il la gagnera il
la gagnera dans sa carrière c'est une
évidence c'est
enregistré ça c'est sûr ça c'est sûr je
mets je je mets je
mets un Paris contre contre Greg canal
euh non là je suis sûr de gagner c'est
pas mais il va la gagner le le le risque
et le X c'est que ça sera peut-être pas
avec le
psgor mais c'est vrai que Anelka moi
j'ai tenu à lui rendre hommage parce que
bon il est déjà de notre territoire et
en fait il a excellemment bien commencé
sa carrière il faut le rappeler il a
gagné la Ligue des Champions avec le
Real Madrid il a gagné aussi l'Euro 2000
faut pas l'oublier avec avec l'équipe de
France donc il a quand même des beaux
titres et c'est vrai que après il a eu
donc de nombreux clubs des clubs très
clinquants aussi des expériences moins
moins clinquantes mais c'est vrai qu'on
a tendance à oublier à cause de ce qui a
pu se passer a sur sa fin de carrière
notamment voilà on se rappelle
douloureusement ou pas de l'épisode à
naisna en Afrique du Sud lors de la
Coupe du Monde 201 la une de nos
confrèreséqu la Une de de des confrères
de l'équipe avec voilà cette embrouille
avec Raymond domenek donc moi je tenais
aussi à lui rendre hommage parce qu'il a
remporté cette Ligue des Champions mais
oui le joueur qui est le plus amé mais
qui a le plus de chance de la remporter
à cause de son talent notamment grâce à
ton talent même plutôt bah c'est Kyan
Mbappé et il aura pas le choix dans la
date dans dans cette vie est PSG pour la
gagner ou pas mais en tout cas je pense
que dans carrière il pourra la remporter
petite précision Grégor vous n'en avez
pas parlé il y a la dolce vita à
enencour Dolce Vita un restaurant
italien qui propose la pizza Nicola
Anelka donc vous pouvez manger à la
pizza Nicolas Anelka vainqueur de la
Ligue des Champions en 2000 elle est
bonne ou pas je l'ai alors vous allez
peut-être pas être content mais je l'ai
jamais goûté je crois qu'il il y a de la
crème fraîche dessus voilà c'est une
pizza assez assez robuste voilà et en
tout cas oui la dolchevita c'était un
peu la cantine de Nicolas nelka qui est
origin de la ville d'à côté trapppe je
voulais qu'on termine par une note de
cuisine on a commencé par de la cuisine
on termine par de la cuisine et une
bonne pizza c'est déjà la fin de cette
cette émission cette j'avais mis la
première émission de la saison mais on
est déjà la 3è émion de la saison on va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
citation aujourd'hui je vous propose une
citation du champion français Bernardino
champion de cyclisme vainqueur à cinq
reprises du Tour de France il faut
parler quand on est sûr je vous laisse
méditer sur cette phrase à bientôt sur
TV 78
[Musique]
efface